shouldn't Marxism be treated the same
way Nazism is treated in academia and
elsewhere shouldn't funding violent
revolutionaries be treated the same as
funding terrorists and those assets
seized wouldn't those two changes and
all of this no so first of all I hate
this because I don't want to be
defending communism I will make the same
point that always gets me in trouble
which is that there is a critique inside
of Marxism which is not so easy to
dismiss there is a plan which is crazy
that we know doesn't work and I would
argue that actually somehow in this
discussion we are missing the central
fact which is that the world's most
boring conversation which is about
whether or not a group selection is an
important evolutionary force is the key
to understanding why Marxism when
translated into communism does not work
so somehow we are gonna have to get up
to speed on why this plan every time it
evolves and it doesn't have to come from
Marx you can have people reinvent the
plan and decide hey wouldn't it be cool
if we all point in the same direction
redistributed everything that plan is
not gonna work but I tell you what I'll
give you something tantalising cool the
body is communist the body is communist
in the following sense from each
according to his abdomen body everybody
ok this isn't a political statement
you're making no this is a topical
physiological statement oh yeah ok go
from each according to his ability to
each according to his need that's how
the body works right why does it work
because all the cells have the same
genome they have no reason to disagree
over this plan right so the point is
altruism is built into the way you
structure it why won't that work with
people because our genomes aren't the
same until yours does not communist two
trees communist but a forest is not
correct correct so if you understand
that then the point is listen you
communists you've missed this important
biological fact do you want to get us to
all point in the same direction do you
want well-being to be wired to
distributed the answer to how you do
that is through enlightened
self-interest and cooperation it is
possible it is possible to build that
system but it will
not be communists that's not how you
will get there that thing is unstable
and the reason that you get gulags and
other forms of oppression traveling in
tandem with this mode is that the
failure of it to work forces you to rien
cent avise things for people in other
words what causes people to behave in a
communist way is the threat of death or
being imprisoned and all that stuff we
don't need to go down this road we've
discovered it already many times over
let's not rediscover it do you want to
redistribute opportunity I'm all for
redistributing opportunity right but if
you get stuck in the redistributing
wealth conversation you're never gonna
get there right opportunity should be
broadly distributed any honest
capitalist should tell you that right
they want opportunity broadly
distributed if they're honest because
that's the way the maximum amount of
good stuff gets done right when you have
people sidelined people who have
incredible capacity and they're
sidelined cleaning somebody's toilet
that's a waste that's somebody who might
have invented something awesome who's
doing something that you know a robot
should do right so distributing
opportunity broadly great but let's
build it on a foundation that makes some
sense and that involves known things
right cooperation that is based on
enlightened self-interest so one of the
key misunderstandings then is that the
body being a human body or a tree's body
or whatever is effectively communist
because all of the cells and systems in
that body have shared fate this is the
concept that this is maybe one of the
concepts I find most important from
evolutionary biology that they have
shared fate whereas the trees in a
forest have some shared fate but not
wholly shared fate just as the people in
a village or a town or a nation can not
have fully shared fate whereas we all of
us on the planet do yeah right so so we
have we have a planetary shared fate but
that's too big to to regulate at the
same kind of level that we need
regulation and good governance and
effective governance at the more local
scale but bodies can act individual
human bodies are effectively communist
in a way that that core
operations and towns can not be because
there is incomplete shared fate well I
want to add something to the mix shared
fate is very important but frankly I'd
argue nationally we have shared fate
right if we recta nation we're going to
be collectively screwed but there are
two things that work in the body's favor
in establishing corporal communism or
whatever you would call it
one is the shared fate and the other is
the complete absence of conflicts of
interest it's like I mean III put that
under shared fate they're distinct right
you can put a bunch of people who might
have conflicts of interest in a rowboat
and they might still have shared fate if
it goes under right but the body by
having a genome that accounts for every
cell means that your liver is more than
happy to surrender whatever resources it
needs to to make your heart function
because it would be suicidal not to
and so the notable exception of course
being cancer well and cancer is
basically I won't say this in every case
because there are cancers that are
contagious and things but in general
cancer if it functions the way we think
it does is incoherent it's like renegade
cells that frankly don't have an
interest in being renegade because they
create a tumor that yes it grows but
it's a dead end so so yes the body has
an overwhelming reason I mean you know
the body cooperates to get the gonads
into a position that they can actually
produce some next generation that's
that's the game but they have every
reason you your liver doesn't want to
freeze out your eyes it wants your eyes
to have everything they need to make
them work great so anyway yes that's the
analysis great
[Music]